the Hema city this year whoa Jamal  Murray and Russell Westbrook get into it  technical foul  what's up Marie and now  Paul George trying to separate  Adams holding onto yogic  Jamal Murray tried to look like he's  tried to step inside of Westbrook and  Westbrook shoved him out of the way  gomez and Westbrook John those yoga  [Applause]  and you love it you really do you love  that sensitive these guys are playing  with Jamal Murray we talked about it  won't back down from anybody and we know  Russell Chauncey look at Mike come along  he just went and grabbed Jamal Murray  and got him out of there and you know  what he's doing he's coaching he's  teaching right now saying we're  positioned to win this game it's okay  you got to see this team down the road  at some point  you'll have your chance to out duel